jean marc bonjour alors on savait que la
banque par la banque de france que
l'épargné global avait été très
abondantes depuis le début de la crise
dans s'aperçoit par cette enquête 1
qu'elle est très inégalement réparti les
riches ont de plus en plus d' épargne
les pauvres de moins en moins comment
vous l'expliquez écoutez c'est une
enquête qui a été réalisée d'ailleurs à
la demande d'un organisme de crédit à la
consommation cofidis et qui était assez
fouillée qui complète finalement de les
informations qu'on nous avions en
provenance de la banque de france alors
globalement que la crise creuse les
inégalités entre les riches et des
pauvres
ce n'est pas un scoop ça c'est à un peu
toujours passé comme ça mais là on a
assisté à un phénomène dans la
répartition de la richesse qui est assez
compliquée et sophistiquée ça s'est joué
en trois axes le premier acte pied au
début de la crise
souvenez-vous à avec le confinement dont
on a vu un gonflement des comptes
d'épargné notamment d' épargne populaire
la caisse d'epargne petit écureuil tout
ça la raison en est simple c'est que les
revenus ont été protégés ils ont été
protégés pour la plupart grâce au
chômage partiel
mais comme tout était fermé les
commerçants étaient permet on rester
chez soi donc on ne dépensait pas la
plus grosse dépense
c'était là dépenses alimentaires et puis
l'abonnement à netflix le reste bas
allez on épargne directement en épargne
et puis il ya eu un deuxième acte le
deuxième axe c'est à la fin du
confinement disons à partir du mois de
mai en juin juillet les français vont
rattraper ce qu'on pourrait appeler la
fièvre acheteuse voiture vêtements
vacances en france on va assister à un
petit bout de la consommation rattrapage
est un peu fier stage du petit boom
parce que ça aurait pu être encore
beaucoup plus important
alors qui va consommer tout le monde les
riches comme les comme les classes
moyennes les cartes bleues vont chauffer
mais là on va observer un phénomène très
particulier c'est que les classes
moyennes ou les classes pauvres vont
puiser dans leurs revenus et y vante
visé dans leur épargne celle qu'ils
avaient accumulé pendant le confinement
y vont puiser dans les bas de laine
ils vont prendre même du cash et et les
régions et bien les riches
ne vous pas prendre dans leur état ils
ne vont pas prendre un pacte ils vont
emprunter pour consommer ils vont
changer de voiture refaire la déco des
appartements racheter des ordinateurs
portables et la secte ça va être un vrai
boum ça va être un vrai boom de
consommation ça va être un vrai boom
d'emprunt ils emprunteront parce que le
crédit est bien il est facile il est pas
cher et puis le troisième acte est bien
le mouvement va continuer d'exister vous
avez la france qui est en train
aujourd'hui mais qui ne touche pas à son
épargne et puis à côté vous avez une
france y puise dans son épargne pour
consommer y compris dans le cash il ya
beaucoup de cash actuellement en
circulation et qui sortent donc on s'est
aperçu que les plus riches poule 10 6 et
10% gros des français ont gardé leur
épargne alors que les autres et bien en
ont désormais un peu moins sur les
livret à la caisse des pales par exemple
on a eu jusqu'à 120 milliards
des panneaux aujourd'hui ces réserves
sont tombées à moins de 80 milliards
globalement est-ce que l'épargné des
français restent importantes jean-marc
oui oui alors globalement ça reste
considérable ça reste je dérape c'est
d'ailleurs un des problèmes macro
économiques auxquels nous sommes
confrontés pour les plus modestes et une
épargne de précaution parce qu'ils ont
peur de perdre leur job livret a le
petit écureuil alors bien sûr et cuisses
de temps pour consommer pour maintenir
un peu leurs dépenses mais il en garde
quand même en réserve pour les français
les plus aisés
c'est une épave qui est en attente
l'investissement elle est importante sur
les comptes courants sur les assurances
vie en euros c'est de l'épargné liquide
disponible qui ne le veulent pas
utiliser parce qu'ils peuvent emprunter
je le disais il ya un instant
alors si on ajoute à toutes les formes
des pabx toutes ses formes n'est pas bon
on arrive à un impact of the skies bien
supérieur à 1000 milliards donc vous
rendez compte c'est une réserve de
relance économique considérable si cet
argent était dans l'économie on aurait
beaucoup moins de problèmes au niveau de
la croissance du haut niveau de l'emploi
donc l'idéal serait de réinjecter cet
argent comment peut-on faire
alors ça c'est le bea va d'économie
l'epag il n'est ni consommer ni investi
ne sert à rien et c'est vrai que les
plus riches
aujourd'hui c'est quand même un paradoxe
ont de l'argent qu'il ne sert à rien
alors il monte
gîte sur la façon de récupérer cet
argent et de le réinjecter comme vous
dites dans l'économie la première
méthode
on pourrait évidemment créer un impôt
tout le monde y pense ça fait longtemps
vous imaginez vous dirais que c'est
tellement facile de mettre un impôt
supplémentaire sur les pagnes sur les
palmiers riche ceci dit ça a quand même
des contre-effets parce que ça perdre sa
de sa dissuasion
ça faciliterait les évasions et puis on
est déjà dans un pays où il ya
pratiquement 60 % de prélèvements
obligatoires
donc c'est pas possible deuxième méthode
créée une incitation à investir bercy et
je crois que ça va sortir incessamment
sous peu près par un projet les produits
financiers qui capterait cette épargne
pour la fléche et où ça est bien là où
on en a besoin c'est à dire dans les pmc
pme sont étranglés par le manque de
trésorerie et à l'étranger par le manque
de fonds promis sion et qui créent les
emplois soit 10 pour la passante d'auxi
eux qui ont besoin de cet argent
et puis la troisième méthode merci
attendre attendre que le virus
disparaisse parce que ce jour là la
confiance reviendra
et si la confiance revient et bien les
acteurs feront des projets consommation
l'investissement et à ce moment là ça
passe on recommence à reprendre des
risques
il consomme on voyage on investit mais a
priori 1 on a tous compris que le virus
avait quand même l'air j'espère avec
nous et pour un bon moment
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre
d'avoir répondu à notre question je
rappelle que vous êtes un éditorialiste
économique